what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are finally getting
to the house strongest Eskin or video we
are going to be looking at all the
evidence we got to determine how strong
s Kannur is at his best since s kannur
just got his power back it seems like
the perfect time to make this video if
you're as hype design that s canora's
back you might want to consider getting
one of our s Kannur t-shirts like Eskin
or praise the sun and s Kannur all hail
the one you can find them both at anime
uh procom along with other anime and
seven deadly sins shirts these shirts
are my favorite personally along with
bond love the pain if you want more
similarly since content on this channel
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos and hit that notification bow so
you don't miss any new ones there will
be a lot of manga spoilers you've been
warned
now without further ado let's jump into
it even before s Kannur was introduced
naka ba suzuki the creator of the seven
deadly sins suggested in an interview
that some members of the seven deadly
sins like Merlin and s Kannur had yet to
be introduced because they were too
strong it seems like naka ba likes
waiting to introduce stronger Opie
characters later that interview alone
hype sup s Kannur who was the last one
he waited to introduce and he was
definitely worth the wait
then we first see s Kannur in the side
story manga vampires up at Umbra Mele
oldest mentions that as always s Kannur
sacred treasure is way too heavy
having Mellie Otis the captain of the
seven deadly sins say this makes s
Kannur seem all the more powerful
however since he comes to pick up s
Kannur around midnight he's currently at
his weakest state in this state has the
lowest recorded power level only 15 we
are even told in the manga that s Kannur
looks crazy week when he's introduced
knockabout loves subverting our
expectations and this is just one of the
many ways he does it luckily we don't
have to wait too long to find out that
all the hints about s canora's great
power words all talk s Kannur is the one
who goes up against the strongest
vampire of them all the vampire king
israel although nighttime s Kannur is
clearly losing at first things quickly
change as s Kannur begins his daytime
transformation he goes from cowering in
fear to
asking the vampire king to apologize to
him for ever being born into his world
we also see him carrying the one-handed
axe that Mellie Otis was having trouble
carrying except esken or is carrying it
with one hand s Kannur backs up his
prideful talk with his strength
the vampire king goes full strength to
try and beat Eskin or merlin notes he
has a power level of 4890 keep in mind
that's higher than every other sins
power level at this point yet s Kannur
is unfazed by the Kings full power s
kannur goes on to say some epically
prideful things like that the darkness
feared him and that while Kings such as
Ezra are as numerous as grains of sand
ESCA nor is no such thing he is an
existence unlike any other in the world
the Lions and a bride askin or askin or
so strong he even looks that upon kings
of powerful races like vampires the
vampire King wraps himself in black full
plate and armor of darkness that is
impregnable to the fires of purgatory
however this armor birds away in s
canoers presence and so does the vampire
Kings flesh the strongest vampire was
defeated by esken oars proximity alone
he didn't even need to raise his hand
Merlin tells us the esken oars power is
completely different from those found in
any of the other nonhuman clans she
explains as the Sun rises his power
increases hour by hour until noon and at
his peak power level he easily surpasses
that of any of the other sins if that
isn't an Opie introduction I don't know
what is not only does he stand at the
top of the human clan Merlin suggests
that he stands atop all clans in terms
of power
his official manga introduction is no
less impressive remember that for the
most part
Galland was more than a match for any
other sent up to this point go through
how to trick him into thinking he killed
Melly Otis so he would leave because
they couldn't beat him physically and
bond had to run for his life when he
faced him mulaskey low space is more
frightened than we've ever seen it up to
that point when s Kannur takes his first
swing at Galang
not only does Galan go full-out he even
uses his critical over mode which
drastically increases his power level to
40,000 we haven't even seen really
honest fight this version of him
nevertheless with his most powerful
swing he can barely draw some blood from
s kannur then when it's s canora's turn
again to take a swing Galan realizes
he's so overpowered that he runs away in
fear ignoring his own commandment and
thus turning into stone
Velasco then tries to eat s canora's
soul but the soul burns her from the
inside almost killing her before it
returns to s canards body in a few pages
s canora's power completely embarrassed
these previously feared characters in
Chapter 169 the implanted thought of
Merlin alone helps s kannur transform
into his daytime version without the Sun
s Canora calls his divine acts Rita to
him which absorbs the tremendous heat he
gives off and stores it until he wishes
to use it he then uses this ability to
significantly damaged role and gloxinia
to other Commandments and former Kings
in this way s Kannur shows that he can
be a force to be reckoned with even
during the night time and now we've
arrived to one of the most epic fights
in the series s Kannur vs. esta rosa
esta rosa has previously completely
overpowered and killed Mellie Otis
albeit temporarily he was depicted as
one of the strongest Commandments up to
this point if not the strongest he also
had a handy ability that lets encounter
all physical moves he tries to engulf s
canora's cruel Sun attack in darkness
but it doesn't work s canoer senses
attack a Testarossa completely taking
him out of commission for the
foreseeable future the combined power of
a serosa and cell dress the two
strongest Commandments wasn't enough to
stop s kannur or his cruel son attack
but the craziest thing is this isn't
even askin ORS full power it is only
when he faces an assault mode meliodas
that we get a taste of s canora's most
powerful form well ask allah says that
malleolus in this mode is as powerful as
he was in his heyday when he was the
leader of the ten commandments
melioidosis beating s Kannur right up
until noon then according to Merlin
during that time for just one minute
s Kannur becomes the invincible
incarnation of power and its name is the
one Mele Otis gives him one thousand
divine slices and it doesn't even seem
to faze the one in contrast to the one
thousand slashes that Mellie Otis gave
kannur with his weapon with one swipe of
his hand askin or takes out Mele Otis
then Eskin or asks him as a god of
demons how does it feel to be looked
down upon by a human then we are told
that at the pinnacle of all stands this
man s kannur now we'll get back to this
moment later but remember that we are
told by Merlin that the one is
invincible and we are told by the manga
that s Kannur in this form stands at the
pinnacle of all next time we see the one
mode is during Chapter 288 zelgius uses
ominous nebula a moved so fast and
powerful that no one not even Ludo shall
with the fastest grace flash and a power
level of 205,000 could stop again at
this point we are told that the one is
the incarnation of invincibility and
unparalleled power ominous nebula is too
strong for s Kannur to use rena so he
has to cast it aside with his bare hand
the one stops on this nebula
so I'll just man just to stop the attack
with his sword but then s Kannur takes
him out with a finger while Chandler
blocks out the Sun causing s Kannur to
turn back into his nighttime form that
was the last time we saw s Kannur in the
one mode but in Chapter 317 miles says
there's still time before noon implying
that we will get to see the form for a
third time but how strong is s Kannur in
the one mode there's some seemingly
conflicting information out there so
let's go over it
when we are told that the one is
invincible and the mightiest are we
supposed to take that seriously or is it
just the hype up the reader during that
chapter it is true that the one has
never lost a battle yet
however people in the comments have
pointed out that grace is just a
fraction of the supreme deities power so
s can or shouldn't be able to get
anywhere close to the demon Kings power
who is supposed to be on par with the
supreme deity that seems logical and s
Canora says himself in Chapter 317 that
getting his power back doesn't mean
he'll suddenly be able to rival the
Demon Lord it was also suggested in the
past that mile would sunshine is
stronger than s Kannur with sunshine it
would make sense because an archangel
and the grace was specifically given to
him so he should be
better vessel than a weak human body
there was also the moment when Miele got
close to zelgius when he used ominous
nebula and zelgius the sword simply
melted from mile just being close that
same sword held back the wands karate
chop and did it melt while a post new
Miele just had to get close so it seems
straightforward enough that did one
should not be able to be on the demon
King's level especially since smile with
sunshine was no match for the demon king
when he took over millio toises body
ludo shell even tells mild that he can't
possibly win against an opponent like
him for these reasons I assumed that mal
with sunshine could be about as powerful
as king with full-grown wings
hypothetically let's say they were able
to attain a power level of four hundred
thousand-plus Eska Knorr the one would
be around three hundred thousand-plus
that was my thought process for a while
but for fun let's take a look at the
possibility that mile isn't necessarily
stronger than Eskin ores the one after
all why would s Kannur walk mile to give
him the power of sunshine back if mile
could just use it better to help his
friends that doesn't seem to make much
sense you want to ensure the safety of
your friends above all else by bringing
the strongest man to the fight so to me
this suggests that miles power what
sunshine may not be out of the one's
League keep in mind sunshine waited 3000
years before finding someone who was
worthy to inherit its power and the
person sunshine chose after all those
years was Eska norm that can't be a
coincidence
let's also take a look at the
transformation as canora's body
undergoes with sunshine Miele doesn't
seem to undergo any dramatic body
transformations whether it's day or
night I was hoping to see mile into one
mode but perhaps he cannot attain that
form only s Canora can perhaps eScan or
had to give the power to mild before
because noone had passed and he had no
hope of turning into the one again for
the rest of the day but in the one form
he could achieve even greater power we
know that everyone has special abilities
in the seventh of these sins bond has
snatch King has disaster and so on but s
Kannur never had an original power
perhaps his original power has to do
with making him an especially powerful
vessel for sunshine because as we saw
his body was
Shyne doesn't follow the same rules as
miles body with sunshine and that is why
sunshine picked him after 3,000 years he
was the only one who could unlock its
full power thus it's not just that ESCA
noir has a fragment of the goddesses
power he can combine it with his own
original power to reach a whole new
level of strength that is not limited to
the power of that one fragment itself
although Eska Knorr body is hurt more
from using the power than miles that
does not mean that s Kannur cannot reach
an equal or even greater level of power
you might be asking what about the fact
that my all melted is all just a sword
while the one didn't perhaps Eskin or
weakened it before or perhaps the heat
can just radiate better through mile a
goddess who never stored any of it
within the divine axe Rita it is worth
mentioning that Eska Knorr the one had
no problem fighting zelgius walls I'll
just did have a prolonged fight with
Maya and even managed to get some good
hits on him that worried mile the one on
the other hand never looked worried he
never does so that is another theory for
Eska Norris the one power we were told
on multiple occasions that it makes him
invincible and the strongest and
honestly that statement hasn't been
proven wrong yet he easily defeated
every opponent he thought and that
includes Mellie Otis and zelgius who
were both arguably at a divine level of
power so yeah for o-p-s Kannur fans
there is hope that s Kannur is the one
could be right up there among the
strongest I would love to believe that
but let me know what you think in the
comments and that is it for today's
video thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed this video make sure to
smash that like one to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell for more
seven deadly sins videos like this one
remember to grab your Eskin or praise
the sun and Eskin or all hail the one
shirts at anime are procom link in the
description I especially want to thank
our pro hero to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson and Kings eldress and are the one
tier patrons after this video I don't
have to tell you that they stand atop
all clans a17 ffvp Steven and Radha
madam AK 2 3
9 and makoto-kun and the super special
patron whose greatness transcends this
plane altogether Regan Harrison the one
who has been acknowledged by Lord
Wiggles set by sama himself if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com slash anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these inspiring people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord
so check out patron accomplished an Amir
link in the description if you're
interested anyways thanks again for all
your support praise the Sun Big Daddy
sunshine is back and until next time see
us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]